foreign
[Music]
creepy but also so effective is their
ability to rapidly adopt new lingo
replacing one word with some other
nonsensical Newspeak term all at the
same time you know all together they're
able to do this virtually overnight a
word that we all had been using without
issue suddenly becomes offensive
and some other term that was invented by
leftist activist 19 seconds ago is put
in its place this process can happen so
quickly that a word you said openly
during breakfast might be a slur by the
time you're sitting down for dinner
meanwhile a term that you've never heard
when you were eating breakfast might be
ubiquitous by dinner time ubiquitous at
least in the media pop culture even if
not among normal human beings and think
about how quickly gibberish like Latin X
showed up on the scene and was adopted
by our institutions or consider how the
term person of color entered the
vernacular and supplanted the previous
PC favorite African-American so we've
seen this process play out many times
and now we have a chance to witness it
once again
while discussing and Reporting on and
very often lying about the death of
psychotic violent Drifter Jordan Neely
the left has collectively embraced a new
label to describe Neely's living
conditions or former living conditions
to be precise there was a time a far
less sensitive sensitive time when um he
would have been described as a vagrant
or a transient or a a bum or a you
know all these words have been used all
these descriptions though have long
since been tossed on the linguistic
ashib and we've settled eventually on
homeless which we all seem to agree
sufficiently sort of
captures the essence of of uh this the
people who are living in this condition
without being judgmental or insulting
you know a homeless person is a person
without a home why don't they have a
home is it their own fault that they're
in this situation or are they victims of
circumstance or is it some combination
of the two well the term homeless passes
down no verdict on those questions and
isn't intended to pass a verdict on that
the word is neutral on why it only seeks
to describe the what
it's a fine word
it's a word that worked perfectly fine
we didn't need a new one but now we have
one anyway see if you can spot the
language shift as we run through a a few
media reports
so this is from axios Jordan Neely an
unhoused man died after being placed in
a Chokehold by another New York Subway
trained passenger during an apparent
mental health episode
the guardian according to new accounts
Neely who was unhoused and a known
Michael Jackson impersonator boarded a
Northbound F train and began screaming
about his distress Philadelphia Inquirer
Jordan Neely's death was ruled a
homicide after next Marine held him in
Chokehold on the subway now it's
sparking discussions on mental health
care for the unhoused The Intercept says
the nypd's treatment of a white man who
strangled Jordanelle an unhoused black
man on the subway is now uh is not how
things usually go down USA Today nearly
had been arrested 42 times since 2013
including charges of assault and Transit
fraud but that many were for minor
violations like having an open container
of alcohol Authority says it appears
nearly was unhoused
so you probably picked up on it it's not
exactly subtle and Democratic
politicians have adopted this
terminology as well here's
representative Jamal Bowman on CNN last
night listen
as a black man watching the video and I
have to force myself to watch these
videos because each time there's a new
video there's uh there's more trauma
that that I feel every Gardener was was
choked to death uh George Floyd had a
knee on his neck uh philando Castile
wasn't choked but he was shot to death
on video and now uh Mr Neely and you
know I've I'm born and raised in New
York I I rode the trains my entire life
as a child you often see people who are
unhoused have episodes
yes remember that the next time you make
the mistake of boarding a New York City
subway train when you see a drug adult
homeless guy randomly assaulting and
mugging a commuter nothing to be
concerned about it's just a person who
is unhoused having an episode
unhoused right the memo has gone out
yeah unhoused is the new uh latinx it's
the hot new pc lingo on the market
and you want to get in on the action
before it changes again because
yesterday the word was homeless today
it's unhoused tomorrow it might be I
don't know de-housed then it will be
person of an unhoused persuasion then
eventually habitation challenged and
you'll realize that all this sounds far
too negative still and don't want a term
that sends the message that homeless
people aren't really homeless at all
it's just that they don't have one
single home in a fixed location right
their home is everywhere it changes and
I'll start using terms like house fluid
and dwelling expensive
that's where this leads but for now
unhoused is the new trendy thing
president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
and that is gold I've bought gold from
Birch gold in preparation for uncertain
Economic Times and you can trust them
too you should do the same you can own
gold in a tax sheltered retirement
account with the help of Birch gold
that's right Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold the best part is you don't
pay a penny out of pocket when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have you
know protect your savings with gold
Birch gold has an A plus rating with a
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers you can find out why by
texting Walsh to 989898 and get your
free info it on gold again text Walsh to
989898 today the first step in growing
up and being a real man is getting off
your parents phone plan getting your own
cell phone plan gives you a sense of
Independence and responsibility it's a
step towards becoming more
self-sufficient by paying for your own
finances you'll learn how to budget and
manage your money there are a ton of
cell phone providers out there
unfortunately most of them want to lock
you into horrific contracts and we'll
tack on hidden fees at any chance they
get that's why I'm a huge fan of pure
talk there are no contracts no hassle
and you can cancel at any time Pure Talk
uses the same Nationwide networks as
major carriers so you'll get a the same
reliable coverage you're used to they
offer a range of cell phone plans that
best fit your budget and your needs you
can get unlimited talk text and plenty
of data for just 30 bucks a month
switching over to Pure Talk is so easy
you can make the switch you can keep
your cell phone number you can keep your
phone number all of that is very easy to
do with our Us customer service team you
can make the switch in as little as 10
minutes Pure Talk is so short you're
going to love your service they're going
to offer a money back guarantee 100
money back guarantee you can't get that
anywhere so go to puretalk.com and your
promo code Walsh to say 50 off your
first month that's curetalk.com promo
code walls Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless why is unhoused preferable to
homeless well the website unhoused.org
makes the case this way it explains
quote the label of homeless has
derogatory connotations it implies that
one is less than and it undermines
self-esteem and Progressive change the
use of the term unhoused instead has a
profound personal impact upon those in
insecure housing situations it implies
that there is a moral and social
assumption that everyone should be
housed in the first place
well how in God's name does the word
unhoused come with moral and social
assumptions that don't also apply to
homeless which literally means exactly
the same thing
in our an article in architectural
digest tries to flesh that out a little
bit it explains quote in Los Angeles
mayor Eric arcetti and some members of
the city council have embraced unhoused
in Seattle the city government uses the
uses the phrase uh person experiencing
homelessness the word homeless has
become Inseparable from a toxic
narrative that blames and demonizes
people who are unhoused according to Eve
Garrow homelessness policy analyst and
advocate for the American civil
liberties Union of Southern California
wait a second
is homeless the word homeless is
dehumanizing
says the homelessness policy analyst all
right
the term is increasingly used in a way
where it implies someone is dangerous or
deviant or devious she said or deviant
as a result a less charged term is more
apt
at the same time a related term to
homelessness the homeless has begun to
be seen as othering in May 2020 the
Associated Press updated its style book
to focus on person first language it
said not to use the homeless calling it
a dehumanizing term and instead use
terms like homeless people or people
without housing
ah you see homeless is offensive uh
offensive enough but if you put the word
the in front of it
suddenly becomes even more offensive
you know that word the very offensive
word
why is that exactly
and how can you change the narrative
around a certain concept by simply
swapping out one term for a synonymous
term
and if attaching the word less to a
person homeless has the effect of
diminishing them somehow then wouldn't
have the same effect to attack attach
the prefix on
I mean in one way is unhoused
substantially or definitionally
different from homeless
the answer of course is that it is
indifferent the change is entirely
arbitrary and meaningless and that is
exactly the point
if there is any real meaning behind the
terminology swap it's in the fact that
unhoused sounds slightly more passive I
guess than homeless
it sounds perhaps even it sounds even
more like something that would happen to
a person
without their involvement really
as if they walked outside one day and
turned around to shut the door and their
house vanished I've become unhoused what
happened to my house
the left seeks to remove the elements of
personal agency and Free Will from all
societal problems especially
homelessness or unhousedness they don't
want us to notice or acknowledge the
fact that many homeless people are
mentally ill uh yes and many of them are
mentally ill because their brains have
been destroyed by drugs and their brains
were destroyed by drugs because they
made the decision at some point in the
past to start using drugs
now I'm sure that a large percentage of
the homeless suffered misfortunate
misfortunes in their lives outside of
their control we all have
um but personal choice has also played a
heavy role in many of these cases a
person who makes good choices will
almost certainly not end up homeless
except in very rare circumstances
the left constantly calls for nuanced
conversations but this is the actual
Nuance in the homeless conversation and
they refuse to acknowledge it
okay the unnuanced view of homelessness
is that they're all victims and that's
it
that's the mainstream view that's the
acceptable view that's the that's the
view without Nuance well they're all
victims
um the Nuance is to realize that well
that's
not always the case
we're not allowed to see the homeless as
anything but pure helpless victims the
through and through though there is no
Nuance to the picture that they paint
paint and and that is partly what this
unhoused stuff is all about but that's
all kind of secondary because even if
unhoused has a slightly more passive
more helpless tone to it the distinction
is still mostly arbitrary and the
arbitrariness is the point most of all
as always we find ourselves unwillingly
in this giant game of cultural Simon
says where they come up with new rules
New Concepts new language
and we're meant to follow along out of
pure obedience
now I think I've used the analogy before
of the the prison warden in the movie
Cool Hand Luke who demands that Luke
dig a giant hole and then fill it back
in again and there's no point to the
hole except to dig it there's no point
to digging it except to break Luke's
spirit and get him accustomed to
following orders the fact that the order
was arbitrary that there was no reason
to dig the hole that the task assigned
was so pointless
that's what made it an effective form of
conditioning
it's one thing to use arguments to
persuade
someone to adjust their language or
their behavior it's another thing if you
compel them to adjust their language and
behavior even if they haven't been
persuaded
okay when you can get people to to speak
a certain way
even when they they don't see any reason
why they should be like why why can't I
say this word why is this word better it
doesn't matter just say it
get people to go along with that
and uh there's a lot more power in that
and that is the truly Sinister agenda
behind this language policing that on
the surface always seems so laughable
and ridiculous
which isn't to say that it isn't
laughable and ridiculous of course
and that is why ultimately the term
unhoused is today canceled I'll do it
for this portion shows move over members
block become a member today by using
Code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed